if you've ever suffered through a bad
movie or finished a meal that wasn't
good simply because you're determined to
get your money's worth well you fallen
victim to the sunk cost fallacy the fact
is if you've already invested your money
or time into something you're far more
likely to continue to do so even when
the costs obviously outweigh the
benefits and boy do companies capitalize
on this ever keep paying for a
membership to a bulk store or a gym that
you weren't using or download an app for
a restaurant chain for the points yeah
me too best believe they know how this
works and they're using it to their
advantage want to learn more about
behavioral economics watch us at 2 cents
on
YouTube